stefano anti ad affrontare l'avventura
che cambierà il corso delle vostre vite
allora pronti per si hanno fatto anche
il 5 viene a tutti ragazzi e prende il
via questo nuovo video sono la vj e
forse ho sputato ed oggi siamo su
traffic quest 5 parte ragazzi capelli da
gran figo che si ritrova sto tizio che è
una cosa fantastica vorrei capire che le
ragazzine iniziano a sto punto perché
sono curioso di vedere che caccia al
combinato stavolta anche se la troll cup
la troll cup è un colpo di genio devo
praticamente vincere la troika per
questa è la trama di questo gioco
megagalattico nascendo più o meno come
fatto tra facebook strega mila l'ultima
cosa mi verrebbe da fare è cliccare
sulla palla però io lo faccio giusto
prevedere che cazzo succede
ok non so se vi deprimente il tiro che
ha fatto la palla chiari da cioè i miei
dubbi lo più o meno cliccare su una cosa
è questo perfetto era abbastanza service
allegato
è questo il modo in cui tu giochi a
calcio va bene non c'è problema andiamo
avanti facciamo finta di non lanciare un
body cup
non siamo neanche fino in campo non c'è
tra una sega questo ragazzi sottile per
risolvere ma l'incrocio tra una patata e
sembra che strumento abbia un culo ma è
bellissimo c'è per caso qualcuno che non
mi prende a calci non lo so solo che se
ti prendo [ __ ] allora quello che
c'è dietro zio e lo stadio e ci dovrei
entrare là dentro porta cosa votare no
no dovevi fare qualcosa che non c'entra
una mazza ma non la trovo tipo è una e
una forbice come cazzola prendo legava
ho capito ma cribbio non c'è modo si si
potrà che cos'ha fatto
no vabbè dai hai vinto hai vinto zio
fuori dai [ __ ] subito ecco questo
succeda far incazzare pa vigente l'ho
fatta e recato con mezzo era mai stato
perché l'hanno una si è mossa perché io
perché io devo calciare la loro già
vinto non so neanche che cazzo facce o
quel curiosità per vedere che cazzo
succedeva si cliccava la palla non
perché vorrei
perfetto faccio finta di non aver la
strisciata passo prossimo lega perché
tanto è bastato gli hanno fatto degli
occhi della madonna delle sopracciglia
abnormi ma fallì un naso no magari e
voldemort e non lo so devo comprare la
palla ok ok ma non è che parla e chi è
chiaro che abbassa chiesto va beh sì
certo sarà compiuto ancora poteva
mandare in mongolfiera vabbè non trovo
sexy
basta basta ok si può perfetto ho vinto
la disperazione del tizio mentre beve
vodka è qualcosa di meraviglioso ci sono
c'è il trucco gallo contro qualcosa deve
preferire vere il vodka sinceramente sta
roba perché è ok sono più contento ho
trovato la ricetta della felicità
ragazzi nostra versate mezzo litro di
vodka esita a posto sì bello è qualcosa
di meraviglioso
ecco come etilico non ha senso sta roba
beh lasciamo perdere il coso proviamo a
secco questo cosa cos'è non lo so ok se
n'è andato in casa
ecco perfetto ha vinto lui non fatemi
domande perché non saprei risponde
ancora la faccia da culo che se devo
fare quindi c'è una leggermente pieno di
rho ok un'incudine una radio un ascia
una un qualcosa che sembra c1 di guerre
stellari ma devo andare rosso possono
libera adesso posso passare vero si può
passare grazie figlio di tua mamma io
non so che cosa contro di me ma giuro
che lascia lascia me la tengo la
sciagurata e [ __ ] calmi calmi e
l'incudine ok ok lascia lascia è che
[Musica]
fu poi devo tutto
adesso sto suonando il tamburo a casa
bellissima
[Musica]
poi al telecronista sta avendo un
infarto cosa nostra perché ha perso
perfetti senso che hanno certi livelli
mi lascia sconcertato sempre di più ok
no fatto fatto privato ok e gas sul
sesso e pretendiamo fare il tifo in
mezzo alla strada intasando il traffico
al non perfetto cliccato quello
sbagliato se non cliccare di preciso non
lo so ma riecco si ok ok cosa dov'è dove
la devo mettere un'altra ma due regate
non capita a prefetto una qui e là è la
troverà il filo nel culo dovevo metterla
l'altro spiegatemi ok no no il poche
domande zio che cazzo fatto al ginocchio
sei messo nel forno o tempo passato un
camion sopra non so che cosa è successo
la siringa la siringa per favore non
esattamente lì però va bene
la cosa bella è che una ci si aspetta un
infermiera sexy ma veramente sexy e poi
si trova questo cos'è questo se la
prendi la siringa la prende morgan non
prende possono trovare su tela ti
rinfaccia di una ammetto che sta
crollata e velocità d'avvio però avrei
saputo far di meglio quindi va bene devo
fare il taglio di capelli cioè posso
spuntarli cup è perfetto ragazzi state
per assistere a fa vj all'opera mentre
taglia i capelli e sarà una cosa
immemorabile ve lo dico già bellissimo
un capolavoro d'arte moderna calcio
balilla contro stessa scusa zio a non si
possono usare le mani ok giusto mi
sembra giusto in un gioco del genere
tumori lo stronzo lei può usare le mani
però ti piace vincere facile zio ecco
perfetta sì lo sapevo sapevo le foto 3 a
2 turca pari scommesso che potrà
allungarmi il punteggio da solo se
ronaldo arrendendo cristiano cliff lee
clark che cazzo ok perché gli preciso ma
ha lanciato una banana allora
devo palleggiare o cos non clicco gli
stronzi di merda non mi potete di nuovo
eccolo eccolo lì perfetto non mi arriva
ok è la era più semplice di quanto
pensassi non solo dio mio santo ma che
dove cazzo più parte il naso dal fronte
della gente stavolta davanti allo stadio
portare la coppa portiamo la coppa c'è
un topo morto nella coppa cosa
normalissima ragazzi nessuno interessa
affatto con morto forse dalla scarpa si
pero hanno tutti il nastro della madonna
e non riescono a sentire la puzza di st
scarpa bellissimo à porter soggezione
sembra che stia svendendo campagne
euroni euro neuropsichiatra 50 centesimi
va bene fa ci facciamo finta di ne
andiamo avanti anche se non hanno preso
la scatola non importa no no ecco perché
no nuova grana [ __ ]
e che cazzo però è senti cazzo dice sì
sì mio dio fa mi sono salvato tipo james
bond dimmi di sì sì sì io mi ragazzi
siamo al 16 sono questo alla fine mi
piaci sto arrivando non ci posso credere
e non ci sono così perché stiamo
giocando ad hockey su prato non ho
capito cosa sta affatto ragazzi danze
scozzesi
[Musica]
prova lollo trono l'altro lo no ok non
ho capito perché olè olè di un canada
[Applauso]
cosa cosa è successo
vabbè non l'ho capita ma va bene così
non i venditori di cap questo vendo i
cappelli perfetto zio mi dai una cosa a
prenderne una caso ti voi non lo so
prende un asse asi questa preso un
cappello stortissimo tra l'altro ho
vinto ma perché mi lega che cazzo se
avete donna allora a 00 10 regala possa
impostare il punteggio ma non ho capito
cosa mi può servire effettivamente no ma
li provo a tutti funzionanti pochi i 60
e gli anni sessanta
ok ok la cazzo sui trucchi per questo
sembra che ci ha deviato delle
commissioni ce la posso fare
c'è la posta video segnatamente però il
punteggio è meno uno perché ho segnato
davvero cose non mi sarei sulla traversa
e lega vincere i mondiali non è mai
stato più semplice che mai che non ci
abbiamo pensato mai prima
perfetto che tanto quella è morto va
bene così completa perché all'ultimo ci
se poi ci siamo se la gloria del tuo
paese perfetto a parte fisso che salta a
gambe aperte c'è qualcosa da fare a
parte no no io calcio il pallone in
maniera bellissima dove la cosa da
cliccare di preciso che non vedo che
ancora non capito di paul tizio no no no
cos'è sta roba
c'è una cena barra una barra che non
funziona bellissimo ok che cos'è so
sorride
6 carico zio carico rete rete è vicino
non è non ha segnato una sega invece è
la madre che micheli direi fatto adesso
torna indietro fino a segnare scommetto
che lari colpita in te sarà dietro la
palla è rimbalzata in porta 1 a 0 e
abbiamo vinto l'altro il capo ragazzi
non chiedetemi che cosa cazzo appena
giocato perché non saprei spiegarvelo
non ci trovo un senso ma il tizio più
figo di prima a caso ragazzi pero chi
come sai che mi sia piaciuto addirittura
di 5 hanno dovuto fare di sta roba che
non va senza servita piaciuto lasciato
un commento mi piace anche scritto lì
non lo so perché anche a faccia di
facebook e oneri video tratta nella
descrizione senese prestiti scrive
tecnici vediamo al prossimo video era
ragazzi